every four years Iowa jealously guards
the gateway to the White House
Iowa has done a good job of narrowing
the field and I think Iowans know we
aren't selecting the nominees or
selecting the president we're helping
test who has a good message that
resonates across the parties who will do
well on a national stage in Iowa votes
in its own peculiar way the Iowa
caucuses here at the State Historical
Museum of Iowa they're trying to explain
it with an exhibit it works like this
unlike political party primaries run by
the state with secret ballots driven by
TV ads lumbering sounds the Iowa
caucuses are run by the Democratic and
Republican parties for Republicans by
secret ballot for Democrats publicly an
IO ins demand hand-to-hand contact Iowa
has turned underdogs like Jimmy Carter
and Barack Obama into winners at Bernie
Sanders headquarters they're looking to
redeem a stinging loss in 2016 and the
self-proclaimed socialist revolutionary
and establishment candidate Joe Biden
are trading frontrunner status the
caucuses don't work like voting in most
states with primaries and secret ballots
Republicans will caucus - mostly for
President Donald Trump Democrats will
argue for their candidates
they'll bicker then vote this year Iowa
has new rules some caucuses are so small
voters put a name in a hat if any of
those candidates get less than 15
percent of the vote those votes are
tossed out and those voters pick their
second choice but this year there's a
twist in order to be more transparent
Iowa Democrats are disclosing not just
the delegate total but also the raw vote
totals so conceivably more than one
candidate could claim victory
that means the effort to be more
transparent could lead to more confusion
the caucuses are often criticized as not
particularly representative in a largely
white agricultural state nor democratic
with low turnout dominated by political
activists I do feel that it's unfair to
a lot of people
were unable to take away from the same
time off of work to participate in
caucus but because its first Iowa's ways
the nation give people with fewer
resources the opportunity to present
themselves and eventually get the
resources that they need to run in the
bigger places from these frozen fields
someone will carry the momentum to the
next state sent just possibly the White
House John Hendren al-jazeera des Moines
Iowa